شكرا لصهيب اهلا بكم مشاهدينا مجددا الى
هذه التغطيه المستمره من العربيه للتطورات
الاوضاع في السودان فقد اعلن الجيش
السوداني سيطره على مطار مروي العسكري
وعلى قياده قطاع كردفان كان مراسل العربيه
قد افاد في وقت سابق بان الجيش السوداني
انتشر في محيط قاعده مروي شمال السودان
بعد انسحاب قوات الدعم السريع حيث نشر
عناصر من الجيش السوداني نشر مقطع فيديو
يوثق دخولهم قاعده مروي العسكريه
في مطار
مروي الدولي
القاعده الجويه مرعبين
استلمنا المطار الله اكبر ولله الحمد
رواد المسلحه السودانيه
في المقابل وقبل ذلك اعلنت قوات الدعم
السريع احكام سيطرتها هي الاخرى على مطار
مراويه
نحن الان الشعب السوداني
بشكل كامل والحمد لله اخواننا بالنسلحه
عارف
ين انه في الشعب
معنى من مدينه مروي الان مراسل العربيه
نزار بقداوي اهلا بك معنا نزار حقيقه
الوضع على الارض والسيطره على القاعده
العسكريه
طاهر بالفعل حسب التاكيدات وحسب الشواهد
القوات المسلحه السودانيه الان
تبسط سيطرتها كاملا على مطار مروي الدولي
وقاعده ملوي العملياتيه الجويه
حدثت اشتباكات عصر هذا اليوم حسب البيانات
من المصادر بان قوات الدعم السريع اضطرت
لمغادره هذه القاعده الجويه التي كانت
تتمركز فيها لاكثر من اربعه ايام خرجت
وحدثت اشتباكات على اثر هذا الاشتباكات
عبر الايات الثقيله والمدفعيه غادرت هذه
القوات وتفرقت في مختلف الاتجاهات داخل
الولايه الشماليه هنالك ايضا معطيات تتعلق
الطاهر باعداد الجرحى والمصابين علمنا بان
القوات الجيش السوداني قامت باجلاء الجرحى
والمصابين خلال هذه العمليه التي استمرت
لي يومين وبعد ان تمكنت من دخول
محاوره الداخليه للقاعده وهي ملحقه بمطار
مروي الدولي قامت بجلاء المصابين الى
مستشفيات مروي العسكري ومستشفى كريمه
ومستشفى دونجولا هذه هي وضعيه الاصابات ان
ننتظر ايضا بيان تفصيليه يوضح حجم الخسائر
الضحايا ما الذي حدث فعليا وعملي وضوح
بموضوع اذا كان ما حصل لقوات الدعم السريع
انسحابا كاملا
او يعني خساره كامله يعني سحبت تكتيكي
خساره كامله حجم القتلى والجرحى اذا كان
في اسرى في صفوفهم باملاك كل هذه التفاصيل
لم تتوضح بعد
حسب المصادر العسكريه للعربيه
تمكنت قوات الجيش السوداني او القوات
المسلحه من اقتياد
عشرات العناصر التي تتبع لقوات الدعم
السريع هم الان داخل المقر العسكريه هنا
في الولايه الشماليه هذا مؤكد من قبل
معلومات عسكريه للعربيه
اعداد الذين خرجوا هذه القوات حسب بيانات
الجيش وحسب المصادر طاهر قالت بانها دفعت
القوات الدعم السريع الدفع للخروج وانها
تعاملت عسكريا في هذه المرحله عصر هذا
اليوم خرجت نحو 40 سياره هذا يعني
ويفسر عدد الذين خرجوا من هذه القاعده لكن
المؤكد طاهر بان القائد الان خاليه تماما
من اي وجود لقوات الدعم السريعه التي
انتشرت في عدد من المحاور والاتجاهات في
هذه الولايه
طيب الان بخصوص المناطق الاخرى التي تفتح
عليها
مروي كيف يمكن وصف الوضع هل هناك سيطره
لترف او اغلاق لطرق من طرف او اخر
كل العمليه العسكريه التي بدات باشتباكات
وتحولت الى عسكريه كل المسرح العسكري كان
داخل المطار وداخل القاعده الجويه كل
المناطق خلاف هذه المناطق خلاف هذه هذا
الموقع امنه مستقره الامور تمضي على
وتيرتها المعتاده ليس هنالك للطرق الجسر
الرئيسي الذي يربط بين مدينتي مروي
الرئيسه وبين مدينه مروي التي توجد فيها
القاعده الجويه الحركه فيه مناسبه تماما
الخدمات الان الضروريه متاحه ومتوفره
الاوضاع هادئه تماما لكن نؤكد طاهر بان
العمليه العسكريه فقط كانت في حدود 18
كيلومتر مربع وهو حجم القاعده الجويه
الملحقه بمطار مروي الدولي طيب وضع الناس
الان الحالات الانسانيه
ماء كهرباء طعام قمح خبز انترنت اتصالات
كل هذه الامور متوفره الغذاء متوفر الماء
متوفر انقطعت الكهرباء يوم الامس لساعات
عاده الان الى مدينه مروي مدينه كريمه
الان فيها الكهرباء فيها خدمات الاتصال
خدمات الانترنت الطرق ممسابه هنالك عطله
او اجازه فرضت على المدارس الابتدائيه
والثانويه والمتوسطه يبدو انه للتعاطي مع
هذه الظروف الامنيه لكن الان الامور
منسابه داخل مدينه كريمه المقاهي والجلسات
متاحه بحكم الاوضاع او الاجواء الرمضانيه
مدينه مروي الرئيسه التي توجد بها القاعده
والعمليه الحربيه يوم الامس الان بدات
تعود وتدف فيه الحياه من جديد مساء بعد ان
استمعوا الى الاخبار المتعلقه بالخلوه
قاعده مروي الجويه من قوات الدعم السريعه
يعني حال الناس فيما يتعلق
بمواقفهم مما يحصل ونحن في الايام الاخيره
من يعني الليالي المباركه من العصر
الاواخر في رمضان قبيل العيد
وربما لم يتوقع كثيرون رغم سوء الوضع
سياسيا في الفتره الاخيره ان يصل ان تصل
مالات الامور الى ما وصلت اليه من استخدام
صواريخ وطيران حتى بين هذين الطرفين ولكن
حال ناس ما الذي يقوله لجهه الايام
المقبله توقعاتهم وامالهم
هذه المدينه طاهر هي مدينه سياحيه مدينه
مروي هي مدينه سياحيه بامتياز ياتي اليها
السياح من مختلف بقاع العالم لمتابعه
الاثار لمشاهدتها لمشاهده النيل لمشاهده
منحنى النيل في هذه المنطقه الكره الان
يجلب ويدين لماذا اضطر سكان هذه المحليه
محليه مروي لان يكونوا جزء من هذا
السيناريو المرعب ان تصبح هذه المدينه
الامنه المطمئنه مسرح لعمليه عسكريه الان
هم ينادون بتحكيم صوت العقل ينادون بضروره
ان تتوقف اصوات الرصاص في مروي وفي
الخرطوم وفي ام درمان في كل المناطق التي
اندلعت فيها هذه الاشتباكات والعمليه
العسكريه لكن حالهم الان يتضرعون للمولى
عز وجل ان تعود هذه المنطقه امنه مطمئنه
وان لا يضطر لمغادره منازلهم كما حدث يوم
الامس عندما انما الى مسامعهم ان
مسحا جويا يمكن ان يصل الى هذه المنطقه
وبالتالي
تتاثر كل هذه المنطقه وهذه المحليه لكن
الان هنالك روحي ايجابيه هنالك تفاؤل بان
القادم افضل خاصه وان العمليه العسكريه
الان هدات تماما في مروي عليه فنتوقع ان
تكون الامور اكثر ايجابيه مع اقتراب ايام
عيد الفطر المبارك سنتابع تفاصيل كل ذلك
معك ومع بقيه مراسلينا وضيوفنا اولا باول
شكرا جزيلا لك نزلاوي مراسل العربيه من
مروي
كلهم كلهم
[موسيقى]
في منزل وزير المعادن السوداني محمد بشير
ابو نمو في منطقه بحري بسبب الاشتباكات
بين الجيش والدعم السريع ما ادى الى وفاه
اثنين الى مقتل اثنين من افراد اسرته
واصابه ثلاثه اخرين منهم اثنان من حراسه
نتابع معكم ايضا مشاهدينا مما قاله مكتب
الناطق الرسمي باسم القوات المسلحه
السودانيه عن ان الموقف العام مستقر جدا
وان اشتباكات محدوده جرت حول محيط القياده
العامه مشيرا الى انه تم استهدافه بعض
المباني التابعه للقياده في محاوله لتشتيت
الجهود وتغطيه الهزائم المتلاحقه على حد
وصف القياده ولفت الى انه يتوقع استهدافا
واسعا لمزيد من البنايات حيث يلجا من وصفه
بالعدو الى اسلوب استهداف الافراد
بالقناصه من اعلى بعض المباني ويجري
التعامل مع ذلك وقال نطمان جماهير شعبنا
الى ان قواته المسلحه متماسكه وفي احسن
حالاتها وتؤدي واجباتها بروح معنويه عاليه
وستحسم الموقف قريبا
اظهرت صور لشركه ماكسار الامريكيه للتصوير
بالاقمار الصناعيه اثار الدمار والحرائق
التي لحقت يوم الاحد بمطار الخرطوم
ومجموعه من المباني والجسور في العاصمه
السودانيه
[موسيقى]
صوت الرصاص يصدح في مختلف ارجاء السودان
فالمعارك اشتدت خلال اليوم الثاني من
المواجهه العسكريه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع من بين ابرز النقاط
الساخنه لليوم الثاني مقر القياده العامه
للجيش الواقعي شمال العاصمه الخرطوم
فالاقتتال لم يتوقف في محيط مركز القياده
وسط تداول اخبار عن استخدام اسلحه ثقيله
وغير بعيد عن مركز القياده تواصلت
اشتباكات في مطار الخرطوم مسببه خسائر
فادحه هذا ما نقرته صور بالاقمار
الاصطناعيه والتي اظهرت حجم الضمائر الذي
لحق بالمبنى الرئيسي للمطار والجسور
المؤديه اليه فضلا عن الحريق الذي نشب في
مستودعات الوقود اثار الدمار بدجليه بعد
يومين فقط من القتال كما هو الحال بالنسبه
لمبنى القياده العامه للقوات البريه والذي
تضرر بشكل واضح اما في ام درمان فقد تواصل
صراع من اجل السيطره على سلاح المهندسين
في شمال البلاد وتحديدا في مدينه ماروي
فان الاوضاع شهدت هدوءا حذرا باعلان الجيش
السوداني سيطرته على القاعده العسكريه بعد
انسحاب قوات الدعم السريع القتال امتد الى
عده اجزاء اخرى من السودان من بينها
الجانبين وسط انتشار كثيف للاليات
العسكريه وبرغم موافقه الطرفين على مقترح
الامم المتحده بفتح مسارات امنه للحالات
الانسانيه لمده ثلاث ساعات فقط فان ذلك لم
يحصل بل استمرت الاشتباكات في اكثر من
موقع في العاصمه وخارجها وسام الذهبي
العربيه
نشرت قوه الدعم السريع مقاطع فيديو وقالت
انها لمدير دائره القضاء العسكري التابع
للجيش وجدي محمد فضل الله ويستسلم للدعم
السريع كما نشرت مقاطع فيديو اخرى لمدير
معهد الاستخبارات العسكريه العميد حيدر
محمد احمد وقالت ان عناصرها القت القبض
عليه خلال المواجهات بين الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني
ويتواصل الاقتتال في العديد من المدن
السودانيه من بينها بورتسودان وسواكن حيث
اظهرت مقاطع فيديو انتشارا عسكريا مكثفا
وسط المدينتين
مبروك مبروك
يا معلم
[موسيقى]
اتهمت قوى الحريه والتغيير في السودان ما
سمتها بولول النظام السابق باشعال فتيل
الازمه والتعبئه للحرب ودعت قوى الحريه
والتغيير في بيان نشرته على فيسبوك قيادتي
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع لوقف المواجهات
العسكريه فورا والعوده لطاوله التفاوض
السودان
الان الا وقف اطلاق النار الفوري والعوده
الى طاولات الحوار
ايضا انه هناك ما زالت فرصه رقم
الجانبين العسكريين الاو
نحن
تضررت مكاتب قناتي العربيه والحدث في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم بعد وقوع قصف
جوي طال ابراج النيلين حيث توجد مكاتب
العربيه والحدث دون وقوع اي اصابات
معركه السماء وان كان الهدف على الارض ففي
السودان القوه هنا في القواعد الجويه
قوات الدعم السريع التي لا تمتلك قوه جويه
تعلم ان من يمتلك الاجواء يحسم المعركه
فكانت البدايه من هنا حيث القوه
اشتعلت المعركه حين اقتحمت قوات حميدتي
احدى القواعد الجويه في الخرطوم اشتبك
الطرفان استخدم الجيش ثلاث طائرات عسكريه
حتى الان خلال الاشتباك ضد قوات الدعم
السريع منذ انتشارها في قاعده مروي حيث
البدايه قاعده مروي الجويه تقع شمال
السودان تستخدم غالبا في التدريبات
والمناورات الجويه تاتي بعدها قاعده
الخرطوم وسط العاصمه وعلى غرب الخرطوم
هنالك قاعده الابيض شمال ولايه كردفان
وايضا قاعده وادي سيدنا في منطقه ام درمان
بالاجمال هناك ثمان قواعد جويه اهمها
بالنسبه للطرفين قاعده مروي لاحتوائها على
اكبر عدد من الطائرات واحدثها والاهم مركز
فعال للمراقبه والطائرات بدون طيار وتليها
اكبر قاعده وادي سيدنا وفيها مخاب ئ
الطائرات وعشرات المقاتلات العسكريه غذاء
السالم العربيه
قال رئيس الوزراء السوداني السابق عبد
الله حمدوك ان الوضع الانسانيه كارثي
مشيرا الى ان المعاناه تفاقمت بسبب
الاشتباكات الحاصله بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريعه لكن بنلتقي في ظرف
عصيب وضع يعني اقل ما يوصف به في السودان
انه وضع كارثي
يلتغيقنا اليوم بعد انا في يوم امس
ارسلتني داء
لخصت فيه
ثلاث رسائل
رساله الاولى
كانت لقياده
الجيش وقياده الدعم السريع
وطالبتهم في انه يجب ان تقف هذه الحرب
فان هي حرب
المنتصر فيها خاسر
كما دعا حمدوك قياده الجيش والدعم السريع
لمفاوضات مباشره لمعالجه اسباب الازمه
تقدير يجب ان يعني نعمل على قيام هدنه
تسمح بخلق ممرات امنه تسمح للمواطنين
بانهم يقضوا حاجاتهم في الدواء
والعلاج
والمستلزمات المعيشه من غذاء الى اخره الى
اخره
ايضا
ان اعتقد انه
ما في بديل
لغير ان انا كسودانيين نقعد
مع بعض في حوار يؤدي
لحل مرضي لكل فئات الشعب السوداني
من العاصمه الخرطوم معنا مراسل العربيه
سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك معنا سالم كيف هو
الوضع على الارض الان هل الاشتباكات
مستمره ام هد هدات
اهلا بك
الوضع هادئ الى حد كبير هناك هدوء اكمل
الساعه حتى الان
لا يوجد اي تبادل اطلاق نار على الاطلاق
في
المدن الثلاث بحسب المعلومات التي لدي
الان الخرطوم وبحري
كلها هادئه الان لا يوجد دليل تحركات
عسكريه واضحه في هذا التوقيت هذا الهدوء
ربما يسبق العاصفه وربما يكون هدوء مستمر
ونتمنى ان يكون هدوء مستمرا بالنسبه
للشارع في شارع خالي تماما من الماره
لا يوجد احد في الشريحه يعني لا نعرف اذا
كان ذلك من احد معطيات المعركه بمعنى انه
هدوء لساعه او ساعتين قد يحصل بين فائده
واخرى او انه نتيجه اتصالات
نعم لا نعرف حقيقه ما هو سبب هذا الهدوء
لكن هو على كل حال الان هناك تام في
العاصمه الخرطوم وفي بحرية
لا يوجد لاي تبادل لاطلاق نار ولا اي من
المداخل بخصوص المواقف السياسيه المتابعه
لما يحصل مع كل الاطراف يعني الوساطات
الاقليميه والدوليه مستمره على قدم الوثاق
ولكن لو تحدثنا معك بالتفصيل اكثر عن
الداخل عن المواقف السياسيه في الداخل هل
هناك اي وسطات يعول عليها هل هناك جهات
تعتبر الان بيضه القبان في هذا الصراع
القائم بين القوتين
نعم هناك مجموعه من السياسيين افضل
وبيانات كان اخرهم فضل مناصب رئيس حزب
الامه القومي والذي
اسعد بالخطوه التي قامت بها الامم المتحده
ونداح في الوصول لعلمة جددت دعوه للبرهان
وقال انه مغير قادرين على التواصل مع
البرهان حتى اللحظه
وناشدهم بفتح خطوط هواتفهما حتى نستطيع
التواصل والتواصل معهما لنزع الفتيل هذه
الازمه هذا بالنسبه للموقف حزب الامه
وايضا الحريه والتغيير كانت قد اصدرت
بيانا كذلك يعني تناشد فيه كل الاطراف
بتحكيم صوت العقل كذلك ما شاهدناه الان
حديث رئيس الوزراء السابق دكتور عبد الله
وهو يناشد ايضا بايقاف الحرب والاقتال
ونداء السلام وانه ليس هنالك
حتى الان في هذه القضيه الان في بيان امين
عام الجامعه العربيه يتفق مع امين عام
الامم المتحده اذا السيدان احمد ابو الغيط
وانطونيو يتفقان على ضروره تكثيف
الاتصالات مع القيادات المتقاتله في
السودان وفق البيان من اجل وضع حد
للمواجهات وفقا لما يرد عبر وكاله الانباء
اذن هذا المشترك
فقط وردتني ايضا من احد شهود الاعياد في
منطقه حله حمل في بحري ذكر ان جاءت قوات
الجيش السوداني واخبرتهم باخلاء المنازل
لانهم ربما يكون من حله حمد سيتم ضرب
القصر الجمهوري وهذا بحسب شاهد الاعياد
انا احاول ان استثم من المعلومه الان
لمزيد من التوضيح حولها لكن هذا ما قاله
ذكر انه اخلى المنزل وخرجوا الان من
منازلهم من حله حمد حله حمد هذه
في
اقصى الجنوب الغربي من من بحري
هي غرب مباشره للجسر وهي في
يعني في في قباله القصر الجمهوري تماما
يغسلها من البصر الجمهوري فقط نهر النيل
فهي الضفه المقابله للقصر الجمهوري من
الخرطوم الجمهوريه في بحري وذكرني شاهد
الاعيان بانه جاءت قوات الجيش السوداني
واخبركم انهم يجب ان يقولوا هذه المنطقه
فانه وهي منطقه حلت حمد في اقصى الجنوب
الغربي من بحري المقابل للقصر الجمهوري في
الخرطوم الجيش السوداني اذن وفقا لشاهد
عيان اخبرك بذلك ريثما نتاكد تماما من هذه
المعلومه بانه طلبوا من القاطنين هناك ان
يخلو هذه المنطقه
وبالتالي فعلوا ذلك
بسبب التوقعاتهم لانه هذه المنطقه ستشهد
اشتباكات
نعم هذا ما ذكره لشاهد الاعيان الان وانهم
الان في طريقهم لاخلاءهم
بحثا عن ذويهم الاخرين في مناطق اخرى لكي
يستطيعوا
لكي يستطيعوا ان يبتعدوا عن هذه المنطقه
منطقه الاشتباك حسب وصف الجيش السوداني
وهذه هي بس اذا كنت توضح لنا لو سمحت سالم
هي نفس المنطقه او احدى المناطق التي كانت
اشتباكات سابقه اما انها هذه الناحيه كانت
هادئه والان طلب من السكان اخلاء منازلهم
لانها فيها اشتباكات كانت فيها اشتباكات
حول الجسر لكن لم تكن بالكثافه التي كانت
عليها مثلا القياده العامه للجيش او حتى
مطار الخرطوم او حتى الاشتباسات التي في
بالقرب من جسر الكوبرا والسجن كوبر ليست
بهذا الحجم لكن كان فيها اشتباكات نعم
وكان يصنع فيها ذوي الرصاص وكذلك
المدافع الثقيله وبالتالي هذا لمده ساعه
تقريبا الذي تحدثت لنا عنه قبل قليل ربما
تخرقه اشتباكات متجدده اذا ما سقطت صدقت
هذه الانباء عن طلب الجيش السوداني من
تعطيني حله حمد في اقصى جنوب الغربي من
بحري اخلاء منازلهم قباله القصر الجمهوري
في الخرطوم ان كان الوضع سيتفاقم خطوره
هناك ونحن يعني طبعا نتابع في هذه الصور
المباشره
للوضع في الخرطوم نستمع الى القصف
المتواصل والى الرصاص
وانت لا تزال معنا سالم الهاشمي لتطلعنا
على المزيد حول ما يحصل على الارض من
طبيعه تعاطي الناس حدثنا في بدايه الساعه
نزار بداوي عن وضع الناس عن الحالات
الانسانيه في مروي وعن وضع القاعده
العسكريه والمطار هناك ماذا عن وسط
الخرطوم الان فيما يتعلق بمتابعه الناس
لهذه الاحداث الاحداث بمواقفهم وبحالاتهم
الانسانيه
نعم الخرطوم وبحري وام درمانها كانت في
بدايه هذه الهدنه
هناك تساؤل من المواطنين ان هذه الهدنه
ستسمح لهم باقتناء ما يحتاجونه من مواد
غذائيه ومن معينات في المنازل
لكن تفاجاوا بان المعدل الغذائيه في يعني
ليست كل المحله التجاريه هي قد باشرت
اعمالها هناك اصحاب محل تجاريه يشحون من
ان الركوب بدات تكون فارغه لانه لا يوجد
امداد
القصف وذوي اطلاق النار والقصر
بصوره اذا ساعه للاسف لم تدم اكثر من ذلك
نستمع لصوت الطبيعي بينما نتحدث اليك بين
فينه واخرى نستمع اليه الان
اذا الخرطوم
هذه الليله ايضا على صوت قرقعه الرصاص
اصوات الرصاص عزيز الرصاص والانفجارات
ونستمع اكثر اذا واضح انها يعني تفاقمت
الان
سالم
يمكن ان تتابع الان تفضل عذرا على
المقاطعه
نعم
تواصل بدات مره اخرى اصوات الرصاص مره
اخرى تنتشر وبدات المواجهات مره اخرى هي
ساعه فقط للاسف لم تدم
ستنام الخرطوم مره اخرى على اصوات الرصاص
والمدافع الثقيله والتخطيط عليها كما
البارحه الوضع الانساني ما زال
الى الان هذه الهدنه لم يستطيع المواطنون
الاستفاده منها بشكل جيد لانها كان فيها
مواجهات اولا ثانيا الوضع على الارض
بالنسبه
التي تعمل لديها اذا كان بالامكان مثلا ان
نحصر سالم معك يعني بالتقدير ابرز المناطق
الان التي تشهد لهذا القصف الذي نسمعه
هو هذا القصه الذي نسمعه الان في محيط في
محيط القصر الجمهوري ومحيط كذلك القياده
العامه للجيش السوداني وكذلك
المطار الخرطوم الدولي هذه المناطق التي
هي مشتعله منذ تمام هي معارك الكرب نفسها
اللي تحدثنا عنها في محيط القصر الجمهوري
في محيط القياده العمل القوات المسلحه وفي
محيط مطار الخرطوم الدولي اذا عادت
المعارك والاشتباكات وعدنا نسمع ذوي اطلاق
النار والقصف في العاصمه السودانيه في
محيط هذه المؤسسات
الثلاث الرئيسيه الاهم هذه زاويه ثانيه
الان للسور الليليه التي تصلنا الاشتباكات
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم سالم ونحن
نستمع اذا لا يمكن ان نتوقف يعني مع كل
قذيفه وكل صوت ولكن نحن نسمعها بوضوح
بينما نتحدث معك ومع بقيه مراسلينا
وضيوفنا
يعني ما نعرف عن السودان ان نشاهد الكثير
من
القلاقل الامنيه ومن عدم الاستقرار في
تاريخه ولكن حتى بالنسبه الى الناس في
السودان من يعيشون في الداخل الى
المواطنين هذا جديد بمعطياته بنوع الاسلحه
المستخدمه باستخدام الطيران بالغارات يعني
هذا اقتتال داخلي عسكري بكل ما للكلمه من
معنى وليس ما كنا نشهده في حالات الثوره
او في حالات قمع التظاهرات في بين حين
واخر هذا جديد كليا حتى بالنسبه الى
المواطن ومرعب
كما تسمع الان شاهد كذلك هذه المشاهد من
امام القياده العامه للجيش السوداني
بدات بالفعل هذه الاشتباكات مره اخرى
وتتجدد بين الكر والفرخه
فتره من
الهدوء الذي عنده العاصمه
تبدا وتتجدد
منطقه القصر
تمام ساعود اليك سالم الهاشمي العربيه من
الخرطوم ونبقي كاميراتنا على هذه الصور
لنا استمرار الاشتباكات والقصف المتواصل
في العاصمه بين الطرفين المتقاتلين القوات
المسلحه وقوات الدعم السريع سالم الهاشمي
شكرا جزيلا لك للان
نعود اليها بعد قليل منذ التفجر الازمه
التي بدات بعد التحشيد العسكري الذي نفذته
قوات الدعم السريع في مناطق بمراوي في
الولايه الشماليه القريبه من القاعده
العسكريه الجويه بدات التساؤلات تطفو الى
السطح حول الاسباب الاعمق لهذا التوتر
المزيد في سياق التقرير الاتي التوتر لا
يزال سيد الموقف في السودان خيوط الخلافات
بين مكونين عسكري ومدني فتحت باب التساؤل
حول الاسباب الاعمق لهذا التوتر وتقود في
نهايتها لمارس الماضي وخلاف ورشه الاصلاح
الامني والعسكري الورشه التي اختتمت حينها
وسط تغيب قاده الجيش شهدت خلافات نشبت بين
ضباط الجيش المشاركين في ختام ورشه
الاصلاح الامني والعسكري وقاده قوات الدعم
السريع
ابرز نقاط الخلاف كان صياغه التوصيات
الاخيره للورشه التي تتطرق لاصلاحات امنيه
ابرزها مساله دمج قوات الدعم السريع مع
الجيش وتواريخ الدمج وتفاصيل الرتب حيث
طالبت ورقه الجيش بحصر دمج قوات الدعم
السريع خلال الفتره الانتقاليه التي حددها
الاتفاق الايطالي باربعه وعشرين شهرا ووضع
ترتيبات امنيه للحركات المسلحه الموقعه
على اتفاق جوبا لسلام السودان وفق جداول
زمنيه محدده كما تحدد ورقه الجيش ضوابط
ومعايير قبول التحاق ضباط قوات الدعم
السريع وتسرح من تم تعيينهم بعد سقوط نظام
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير وتقنين صلاحيات
الدعم السريع العسكريه والاقتصاديه
والسياسيه من جهه اخرى الخلاف بين الدعم
السريع والجيش ليس خلافا فنيا حول فتره
دمج قوات الدعم السريع والتي تطالب
الاخيره بان تكون خلال عشر سنوات بل هو
خلا سياسي بسبب تقاطع مواقف قائد الجيش
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد الدعم السريع
محمد حمدان حميدتي تجاه العمليه السياسيه
والتحالفات المستقبليه خاصه ان الدعم
السريع نص بتوصياته خلال ورشه الاصلاح
الامني على مراجعه وتطوير العقيده
العسكريه وناي المؤسسه العسكريه عن التدخل
في السياسه لكن الصراع بين الامبراطوريتين
العسكريتين اعمق من مجرد اختلاف على عمليه
دمج القوات فمصادر مقربه من البرهان ودجلو
كشفت بانهما ما زال على خلاف حول من
سيتقلد منصب القائد العام للجيش خلال فتره
الاندماج التي ستمتد عده سنوات
معنى من الخرطوم الكاتب الصحفي عادل سيدي
احمد اهلا بك معنا استاذ عادل مره جديده
على شاشه العربيه كنا نستمع للاسف الى
اصوات المعارك في
الخرطوم وفي محيط القصر الجمهوري المطار
الدولي وكذلك القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه لم يستطع الجيش حتى الان ان يحسم
سيطرته على هذه النقاط الحساسه جدا
بالنسبه الى ما ستقوله الايام المقبله ما
رايك لماذا
عيد السؤال اخ طاهر
لماذا تعتقد بان الجيش لم يستطع حسم هذه
المعركه في هذه النقاط الحساسه في القصر
الجمهوري محيط في القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه والمطار
كما ذكرت انت من خلال الخبر ان هناك كررا
وفرا من جانب قوات الدعم السريع وانت تعلم
حساسيه للاسف الشديد جزء كبير جدا من هذه
المواقع
ليس ببعيده عن المناطق السكنيه لذلك انا
اعتقد انه القوات المسلحه تقوم بتكون
حريصه جدا على ان تدقق في تحركاتها وتصوب
في اصاباتها تجاه الدعم السريع ولكن بشكل
عام حتى ان كانت هناك مجموعات محسوبه على
الدعم السريعه حول المناطق المهمه كالقصر
الجمهور والقياده العامه انا اعتقد انها
مجموعات تقوم بالكروه الفر وليست بشكل
منظم او بشكل يعني ينتهي الى مثلا
الاستيلاء على القصر او القياده العامه هي
وربما يكون الاهم لا اعرف اذا كنت تتفق
معي وحده المؤسسه العسكريه والقوات
المسلحه اكثر من رمزيه هذه الاماكن يعني
حتى لو تم السيطره مثلا على القصر
الجمهوري او على المطار الان
من قبل طرف هو القوات الدعم السريع تبقى
قوه غرفه العمليات قائمه
البرهان انا كما
وهذا الكلام كثيرا منذ ان المعرض
هي عسكريه
بين جيش باحداده
وبسلاحه المتكامل وبكفاءته العاليه
وبخبرته الكبيره الراسخه فهو يمتلك سلاح
طيران ويمتلك سلاح مدرعات ومشاه وما الى
ذلك جيش مؤسسه الجيش ذا تاسس عام 1925
لذلك له خبره كبيره جدا ولو معتركات حيث
دخل في معارك كبيره جدا
على هذه الشاكله عام 76
وعام 2005 وكذلك بعد الثوره السودانيه
فيما عرف بهيئه العمليات التابعه لاجهزه
الامن انا اعتقد انه المعركه اصلا غير
متكافئه هناك جيش يعني نظامي له عقيده
عسكريه وله نظم وله ومعدات وامكانيات
ومواصفه ضخمه جدا مقابل مجموعه عسكريه
تمتلك قدر محدوده من القوه العسكريه ولكن
متمكن ومتموله ومتسلحه وحاربت كثيرا ايضا
وليس لها نفس الالتزامات كالقوات المسلحه
وبالتالي يعني هذا ما قد يحررها من الكثير
من الضغوط لكي تربح اكثر على الارض
صحيح انا اعتقد انه هذا الكلام بس جدا
ويعني قوات الدعم السريعه الان
له باخر فلذلك تقوم بعمليات انا اعتقد
انها تقوم بها من على البعد من على مسافات
لانه اذا حاولت الالتحام او حاولت
المواجهه المباشره طبعا فان المساله لن
تكون لصالحها لانها لانها ستجد نفسها امام
جيش بكامل لا امكانياته وبكامل شو يعني
تقوم بكل ما تقوم به بشكل غير مباشر يعني
كيف يمكن ان تنتقل الى حاله المباشر بعد
لا انا اعتقد
ذلك هي تقوم بعمليات انا اعتقد ان من على
مسافه يعني من على مسافه بعيده تقوم
بتسجيل هنا تقوم بضرب بمنطقه هناك
لاثبات الوجود ولاعطاء الانطباع بانها
تستطيع ان تلحق الاذى ولكن ليس بالامكان
ان تقوم بعمليه عسكريه بشكل دقيق وبشكل
مهني وبشكل علمي كما هو الحال لدى القوات
المسلحه ولكن قد تكون قادره على ان تصمد
هل العامل الزمني في في صف القوات المسلحه
هنا
انا اعتقد انه ستصمت ولكن الى حين
المؤشرات الاوليه الان في مروي وفي كثير
جدا من المقرات التابعه لدعم السريع تشير
الى انه القوات المسلحه
من خلال امكانيات الجيش العاليه تقوم
بعمليات يعني كبيره
وناجحه الدعم السريعي حاول المقاومه
ويحاول الصمود بالشكل او باخر ولكن انا
اعتقد ان المساله هي مساله وقت
لن يستطيع دعم سريعا يصمت كثيرا في مواجهه
جيش له امكانيات وله خبره وله تجربه وله
كفاءات كثيره ولكن انت اي نهايه هنا
تتخيلها لقوات الدعم السريع نهايه بعد
تفاوض يعود اليها جزءا من الجيش ويعني بعض
الشروط
اذا تحدثنا يا صديقي يا طاهر بفهم بفهم
سياسي وكفاهم
لا احد يرفض الحوار والجلوس للتفاوض وحل
المشاكل من خلال المائده ومن خلال الجلوس
حول مائله ولكن اذا تحدثنا بحسابات فنيه
بحسابات عسكريه بحته فقطع
اقول لك ان موازين القوى لصالح القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وين برايك النقطه التي
سيقبل فيها الجيش الجلوس مجددا الى طاوله
التفاوض واضح انه يريد ان يحقق شيء ما على
الارض قبل ان يقبل بالتفاوض مجددا لكي
ينهي رساله الدماء
وهنا مربط الفرض هنا المشكله التي ستواجه
الجيش يحس بانه يتقدم ويحس بانه من الواضح
انه تحركات الجيش تسير في اتجاه الاجهاز
على الدعم السريع بشكل نهائي هذا هو
التفكير العسكري الذي يدير العمليات الان
انا اعتقد انه
الوسطاء لن يلحقوا ان يجدوا مجالا للجلوس
على مائده خافضوا ان الجيش فيما يبدو ان
خطته تقوم على التخلص بشكل نهائي من الدعم
السريع
الوسطاء يبداون بالاصول غدا على من ابرز
من تعول عليه من هو ابرز من تعول عليه
كوسيط هنا بين الايجاد المفوضيه الافريقيه
الامم المتحده الجامعه العربيه
هناك وساقطات كثيره ولكن الوساطه المصريه
يبدو انها لها اطروحه واضحه تقوم على
تفاصيل دقيقه
فهي ربما تكون لها يعني نصيب من التحرك
الجاد الذي قد يثمر ياتي بنتائج استطاعوا
ان يلحقوا الوضع قبل ان يتفاهم كذلك
المنظمه الايجارات او فدت مجموعه من الدول
هي كينيا وجيبوتي وجنوب السودان وسيصل
وفدا الاتحاد الافريقي غدا الاثنين كلهم
محاولات من هنا وهناك لا احد يدري هل هي
متوائمه مع ما يحدث على الارض ام لا هذا
مصير عليه الايام القادمه شكرا جزيلا لك
سيد عادل سيدي احمد الكاتب الصحفي من
الخرطوم تحياتي اليك
السودان يسقط في وحل الاقتتال بين اقوى
الرجلين عسكريين في البلاد فانقطاع حبل
الود بين عبد الفتاح البرهان ومحمد حمدانو
اوقع السودان في المحظور اتهامات وتوعد
وتهديد بالقتل هكذا تحول الخطاب بين
الرجلين الذين نسفا في لحظات علاقه تحالف
وعمل مشترك دامت نحو 20 عاما الرجلان عمل
سويا لاول مره سنه 2003 حين اتحدا للتصدي
لجماعات المسلحه في اقليم دارفور الملقب
بحميتي انشا حينها مجموعه صغيره مسلحه
ووضع يده في يد البرهان الذي كان حينها
منسقا لعمليات الجيش في دارفور ومنذ ذلك
الحين والرجلان يصعدان المراتب بشكل
تدريجي عاد ليتصدر المشهد سنه 2019 حين
اتحدا من جديد وهذه المره ليس الا لاسقاط
عمر البشير الذي قاتلا تحت رايته سويا قبل
16 عاما
هدف مشترك جمعهما ليبرما تحالفا
استراتيجيا لكن انهاء مهام الحكومه
المدنيه وسيطره البرهان الى جانب حميتي
على الحكم خليفه سنه 2021 حمل معه اولى
شذرات الخلاف الحقيقيه فالبرهان اعاد بعد
عناصر نظام البشير الى السلطه وهو ما
اعترض عليه حميدتي لكن نقطه التي افاضت
الكاس تمخضت عن الاتفاق الاطاري الذي حمل
بين ثناياه مقترح اصلاح النظام العسكري
ودمج قوات الدعم السريع مقترح كان مجرد
قنبله موقوته انفجرت لتنهي تحالفا
استراتيجيا وتشعل عداوه قد تحرق نيرانها
البلاد وسام الذهبي العربيه
معنا من الخرطوم الان طاهر المعتصم الكاتب
الصحفي اهلا بك معنا استاذ طاهر مره جديده
على شاشه العربيه عاد الاقتتال ونستمع الى
اصوات
المعارك بقوه في هذه في هاتين الصورتين
المباشرتين امامنا من العاصمه الخرطوم
ايضا السؤال الذي اساله لضيوف هذه الساعه
ما الذي ما الاسباب التي تعز اليها عدم
تمكن الجيش حتى الان من حسم المعركه على
الاقل في المواقع الاساسيه التي تدور
حولها المعارك الان القصر الجمهوري المطار
والقياده العامه
استاذ طاهر معتصم تسمعني
انقطع الاتصال مع طاهر المعتصم الكاتب
الصحفي قد نعود اليه في سياق هذه الساعه
او في ساعات اخرى شكرا له على كل حال
نتعرف الان مشاهدينا الكرام الى دعوه رئيس
لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي
الاطراف السودانيه الى وقف الاعمال التي
وصفها بالعدائيه وحتى بريء على ضروره عوده
المسار الانتقالي بقياده مدنيه كما شدد
على ضروره وقف التدخلات الخارجيه في الشان
السودانيه
هذا واكد اكدت مصادر للعربيه ان تحركات
مصريه جاريه حاليا لوقف الازمه في السودان
وبحسب المصادر فان المبادره المصريه تاتي
بالتنسيق مع الامم المتحده والاتحادين
الافريقي والاوروبي وتتضمن سته بنود اهمها
الوصول لاتفاق مبدئي لوقف اطلاق النار
والتصعيد بشكل كامل وفق اطار زمني محدد
اضافه الى سحب قوات الطرفين من الشوارع
والمنشات العامه تحت رقابه لجنه دوليه
وتتضمن المبادره ايضا وضع خطه وجداول
زمنيه لتوحيد المؤسسات الامنيه والعسكريه
السودانيه بشكل كامل اضافه الى تشكيل لجنه
عسكريه من الطرفين لازاله النقاط العالقه
خلال اطار زمني محدد للتنفيذ ايضا الدعوه
لعقد اجتماع للاطراف السودانيه في دوله
محايده في حال تعثر الاجتماع داخل البلاد
يعود الينا طاهر المعتصم او كاتب الصحفي
من الخرطوم اهلا بك استاذ طاهر تسمعني
الان
واضح اهلا وسهلا استاذ طاهر اهلا وسهلا
فيك كنت سالتك عن يعني سبب الذي تعزو اليه
عدم تمكن الجيش من السيطره على هذه
المواقع الاساسيه كما هو في الخبر العاجل
الان قياده العامه مطار الخرطوم القصر
الجمهوري
السوداني
التزاموته العتيقه والتزامه للقانون
الدولي
وعدم
طلبه لان تحدث خسائر بشريه
هائله باعتبار ان هذه المعركه معركه مدن
كما تعلم
لذلك يحاول ان يستخدم استراتيجيه مختلفه
في قطع خطوط الامداد لقوات الدعم السريع
استهلاك مقرها حتى
الوقود الذي تتعرض لسياراتهم ومتحركاتهم
وتستنفذ الذخيره
ويضطروا الى الاستسلام اوروبا استراتيجيه
تجعل من الصعوبه بما كان حسن الماضي انت
في الخرطوم الان تستطيع ان تسمع حيث انت
اصوات الاشتباك نسمعها نحن في الصور
هل هذه هي هل هذه كيف تصف هذه الفتره من
الاقتتال هل هي الاعنف
[موسيقى]
يوم اليوم الثاني
وتراشغ بالمدفعيه وترافق بالاسلحه الثقيله
محاولات السيطره من كل طرف ولكن اعتقد ان
الجيش السوداني يبلي بلا حسن وابناؤنا في
القوات المسلحه يقومون بادوار مهمه في هذه
اللحظات
منظمه الصحه العالميه تقول ان 83 شخصا على
الاقل قتلوا وجرح اكثر من
1126 شخصا في السودان منذ اندلاع العنف
بين القوات المسلحه والدعم السريعه طيب
اتابع معك استاذ طاهر فيما يتعلق
يعني كيف بدات هذه المعارك لماذا باعتقادك
حتى لو حصل حتى لو حصل القصف
حتى لو كان من بدا المعركه قوات الدعم
السريع لماذا قرر الجيش الرد يعني بهذا
الحسم وبهذا الحجم
هل قرر انهاء قوات الدعم المشاريع انهاء
حاله حمايه تماما او فرد شروط لكي يقبل
فيها حمايتي بالتنازل لصالح قوات المسلحه
الوضع الذي طرد الصباح السبت كان مختلف
جدا قوات الدعم السريع قامت بمهاجمه
الرئاسه
وقامت بمهاجمه مقر اقامه رئيس مجلس
القياده وغائب الجيش وغام بالمهاجمه
الخرطوم
وفي مدينه مروي
كندا هذه الخطه يراها المراقبون انها كانت
اشبه بمحاوله انقلابيه على الوضع القائم
في السودان بالتالي الجيش السوداني
فورا مقرر ان يقوم بالدفاع عن المغاره
المهمه والحيويه
وقياده البلاد ايضا باعتبار ان هناك عمليه
سياسيه كانت تجري ما يحدث فيها
ولكن لو لم يبدا او تبدا قوات الدعم
السريع
بالرصاصه الاولى لا تعتقد او الا تعتقد
بالاحرى انها فعلت ذلك انها قامت باطلاق
الرصاصه الاولى
درعا لما كان يخطط ربما من بعض القيادات
العسكريه
لمصير حماتي وشقيقه
طرفين ويحاولون تهدئه الاوضاع
صباح السبت يفاجئون باحداث مختلفه
باستهداف للقصر الجمهوري باستهداف لمضار
القياده العامه ومطار الخرطوم هذا الامر
ادى الى تحول كبير وغير مصبوغ
واوصل الامور الى هذه النقطه التي نعيشها
الان تريد ان تقول انه اجبر القوات
المسلحه على الرد بهذه الطريقه استاذ طاهر
المعتصب الكاتب الصحفي من الخرطوم شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه معنا نتابع
واياكم في رصد هذه الصور المباشره بين
فينه واخرى في خلال هذه الساعه المتواصله
من العربيه ولكن نتابع الان في رصد اخر
المواقف الدوليه ومنها ما اعلنه الاتحاد
الافريقي عن ان رئيس مفوضيته مسافقي محمد
سيتوجه فورا الى السودان للتحدث مع
الطرفين بشان وقف اطلاق النار حيث من
المفترض ان يصل يوم غد وعبر الاتحاد عن
قلقه العميق اذا الوضع داعيا قوات الجيش
والدعم السريع الى حمايه المدنيين وفق ما
جاء في بيان صدر عقب اجتماع طارق لمجلس
الامن والسلم التابعه للاتحاد الافريقي
هذا واقلا مكتب الرئيس الكينيم روتو ان
الهيئه الحكوميه الدوليه للتنميه ايجاد
الكتله الافريقيه الاقليميه تعتزم ارسال
رؤساء كينيا وجنوب السودان وجيبوتي في
اقرب وقت ممكن في مسعى للمصالحه بين
الاطراف المتصارعه ومحاوله وقف القتال
الدائر هناك واضاف مكتب الرئيس الكيني ان
استقرار السودان هو مفتاح الاستقرار في
المنطقه
نستمع قليلا الى صوت الطبيعي من المصدر
لهذين الموقعين في هاتين الصورتين
المباشرتين من العاصمه الخرطوم لاستمرار
عمليات الاقتتال بين قوات الدعم السريع
والقوات المسلحه السودانيه
ونحن نتابع هذه الصور نتحدث الى اللواء
كمال اسماعيل رئيس حزب التحالف الوطني
السوداني اهلا بك معنا سياده اللواء على
شاشه العربيه الموقف الان هل يحتمل مع
استمرار المعارك بهذه الوتيره هل يحتمل اي
تدخل اي وساطه انه لا يجب ان نرفع مستوى
التوقعات في هذه الساعات
شكرا جزيلا اولا طبعا يعني زي ما ذكرت
بعده
لقاءات انه دي حرب ليس فيها
مهزوم ولا منتصر المهزومه الاول هو الشعب
السوداني والاطراف المتحاربه لانها يعني
تلاحظ عدد
الاصابات والوفيات والمسائل دي وفي الصفوف
المجانين بوتيره عاليه لانه هذه حرف
نسميها نحن حرق المناطق المبنيه او حرب
المدن اللي هي يعني فيها كميه من المدنيين
وهم اكثر تاثيرا بهذه الحرب كان ممكن ان
يتفادى ان نتفادى جميعا هذه الحرب
كثيرا كان هناك تفاوضات وكنا نحن جزء منها
وكان هناك تفاوض على اساس وصول يعني
القوتين المتحاربتين الان هم موقعين في
الاتفاق الاطاري وكان في موضوع موضوع
الدعم وكذا كان في نقطتين خلاف اللي هم
الازمنه والسيطره في زمن في زمن بتاع
الدمج صحيح تكلمنا مع الطرفين في اجتماع
مهم في القصر الجمهوري بانه هذين النقطتين
يمكن حلها بوجود طرف ثالث ليس مدنيا من
ضباط المعاشات وسمينا ظباط على اساس انه
نجلس ننزع الفتيل وانا ناخذ النقطتين
بالتفاوض مع الطرفين لنصل لنقطه اتفاق
بياناتهم ويعبر لكن هذا لم يحصل وبالتالي
يتفجر القتال وتطلع بي متداوله من هنا
وهناك والاتصالات الان واقفه مش لشي لانه
كل التليفونات مقفله والوضع ذاته ما بيسمح
بالحركه وكده
يعني الوزراء والمسؤولين الدوليين عم
بيقدروا يحكوا معها الطرفين الا سياسيين
في الداخل يبدو انه تليفوناتكم يعني
تليفوناتهم مسكرين عليكم
اللعينه لانه كل يوم يزداد عدد القتلى
والتدمير وطرب البنيه التحتيه لانها المدن
وكنت تامل تماما ان لا يحصل تدخل الطيران
ولا كذا انه لانه
الطيران ذاته في مناطق مبنيه وفي مدن من
الصعوبه انه اي خدمات لكن حصل ما حصل الان
نحن
في وقف اطلاق النار والعوده للمفاوضات مع
اي طرف اذا كان
ذلك الان
اي طرف لو كان بيفتكر انه الحد من طرف
القادم الان بتقديرك ما الطرف القادر الان
على جامعه طرفين
والله المساعي تعرف من كل الجهات يعني في
مسائل مبذوله من كل الاطراف ونحن عايزين
الطرف السوداني يكون هو صاحب المزرعه
الاول والطرف
الاجنبي يكون مسهل وداعم ليس يعني
قليل الطرف الازهري الذي لم يدخل على خط
الازمه السودانيه
قليل يعني في الواقع ان كان افريقي وان
كان عربي وان كان اجنبي
والصراحه ان ان الافرقه السودانيه
المتقاتله هي التي يعني على نفسها جنه
براقش كما يقال يعني هي التي ادت الى هذا
المطاف في السودان لا اشكر لك الجوز سياسي
قبل هذه الحرب دواء السياسي تم فيه قيود
وملب باشكال كثيره جدا ودش عاديه لانه في
العمل السياسي هو وسائل الاختلاف وسائل
الثقه وسائل الحوار وكذا ما في اثنين
ثلاثه لكن في النهايه
في النهايات هذا الوطن هو مؤثر على شعبنا
مؤثر على القضيه السودانيه مؤثره على
الانتقال على اهداف الثوره
يبقى انه التور السوداني هو الاهم اما
الدور
الاممي والاقليني والاصدقاء وكذا وهذول
مسهل وداعم الدوره
السودانيين بانه لم تستطيعوا حل الموضوع
ولن تستطيعوا حل بزمن السلم فكيف الان
بزمن الحرب
والمساله السياسيه دي نحن اول شيء
خلفياتنا عسكريه ونطاليه سياسيه العمل
السياسي هو ليس يعني عمل ساعه ونصف ساعه
حوارات اذا كان انت امنت بالحوار بتنتظر
الحوار الى ان تصل لطريق مسدود نحن نصل
لطريق مسدود في الحوار وبدليل على ذلك
الايطاليه الطرفين وقعت فيه يقول ما وصلنا
لكن هناك ايادي يعني مش مهم توقيع الاتفاق
المهم ان يتم الالتزام به او لا
بات هو كان ماشي وكان حده ايام لانهاء
الاتفاق وكذا حصلت معدلات في عدم الاتفاق
في اللجنه الفنيه وكان مقدور عليهم لكن
بردت اشياء كثيره جدا في ناس او في مجموعه
او في طرف هو لا يريد لهذا الحل السياسي
ولا يريد الاستقرار وبالتالي دفع لكل جهد
غزله
تمام خلق هذه الفتنه خطي هذه الفتنه ان
احنا نقول انه كل
السودانيين مختلف مشارب او نسبه التمرين
تماما
ولكن انتهى وقت هذه الساعه شكرا جزيلا لك
سياده اللواء كمال اسماعيل رئيس حزب
التحالف الوطني السوداني من الخرطوم
تحياتي اليك لمتابع هذه التغطيه مع صهيب
بعد قليل الى اللقاء
متابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات